the red starter his numbers from western
and southern tyler mally
well you can see the numbers right there
and he has been really good 98
strikeouts 26 walks
certainly want to limit the amount of
walks but
mally's ability to throw that fastball
got a devastating split
but they all off the all the off speed
pitches work only if
he's able to locate that fast line he's
got a good one
delivers
swing in the miss chasing down and away
strike three
there's that split what you're talking
about
so guess what kyle muller it's truly red
alert with india leading off and mueller
makes a second big league start yeah
pitch a good ball game against the mets
and jake degram last time out
four innings three strikeouts retired
the last seven batters he faced so same
thing today just get out there pound the
zone with that good fastball curveball
give the braves a chance that's not
always easy
a little pop into shallow right acuna
streaking in and makes a terrific
sliding catch
cutter got a little in on his hands
tried to fist it out there almost did
but ronald closed on that in a hurry
boy off the bat that sure looked like it
had hit written all over it but boy
they've got some guys in this outfield
do the braves that can cover some ground
but he tries to
use to get vatto
he straw came out bottle caught looking
two up two down well a number of things
impressive about that
number one you got hitter like votto up
there in a 3-2 count you got enough
confidence in yourself to throw a slider
but he shook multiple times to get there
muller ready with his 19th pitch
and right on by how impressive was that
the reds one two three hitters have been
the best in baseball and mueller just
mowed him down with a couple of
first-inning strikeouts
peak there he's nearly right behind the
circle runner goes swinging to this
throw down strikeout tag
safe
now did he over slide with the tag on
the reds are gonna challenge i don't
know that that left knee came on when
his right cleat popped off and india
kept the tag on
well you're taught nowadays to make sure
you keep
the tag on the runner just in case
because of replay
what's the word
out
strike about throw them out double play
so if you're watching at home make sure
you keep that tag
on the runner
one ball one strike for the
braves right fielder ronald acuna jr the
pitch
whacked into right center field that's
gonna get down for a base hit around
second is heredia he's on his way to
third they're gonna wave him here comes
the relay throw it is gonna be late
ronald lacuna junior doubles to the gap
and the braves have struck first a two
out run scoring hit it's one to nothing
hit a double with two outs and a guy on
first
nice job by ronald change up there not
where
mali wanted it ronald stayed inside it
drove it in the gap
and with two strikes heredia is off on
contact
reds did a nice job in a relay play
yesterday cut down a run at home but
no such luck today
for the first run of the game
now freddie shoots one into right field
that's a base hit here comes her cunha
flying around third the throw toward the
plate is gonna be cut off at the
diamonds
center joey vano cuts it off freddie
freeman with an rbi hit and atlanta
leads by two
yeah freddie got a pitch up there
and
despite the shift still able to find a
hole
up the middle
rbi single
and hey
braves are one for run one for one today
with runners in scoring position and
nick maybe that'll take some of the
pressure off for this offense i know
brian snitker was asked about that on
his pre-game
night of it lifts this one shallow right
freeman shades on and they bump and the
ball drops in
nobody talked heideman leans off the bag
throw in and he just
best the tag heck of a job by the
pitcher mueller to cover this kian you
really it's tough to communicate in this
situation because if you don't have it
you can't just say i got it i got it i
got it
and then you got to try to avoid
the collision
just a tough spot right there
oh it was in and out of his glove too
trying to avoid the collision
big sequence for kyle muller he's got
two on he's got a two run lead
and two strikes on joey votto
he did and he gets out of it
mueller has struck out votto twice six
strikeouts for the kid left-hander and
he holds a two-nothing lead
and so it's two-nothing
oh
up and in that one got the bat
i think
it was a change-up
wisely let go of the bat yep
it's going to cost him a strike i guess
and acuna fortunate to get out of the
way
you hate seeing misses up around the
hands in the helmet
swing and a rocket hit to straight away
center that's how you pay back
a high tight pitch
ronald acuna junior's 21st homer extends
the lead
yeah you know look no hitter likes
having a ball like that i know ronald
doesn't like it
gets him a little bit mad but i promise
you that played to his advantage the
rest of that at-bat miley was nowhere
close
he wasn't o'malley sorry he wasn't going
to come back in the inside part of the
plate and hangs a slider
and molly's reaction told you all you
needed to know head down said dang it
and that one sailed into the burn in
straightaway center
a no doubter for ronald lacuna junior a
two rbi two run day
[Music]
[Applause]
see what his reaction is if he can get
the reds pitcher here and qualify for
the win
the one-two to the pitcher
swung on a miss struck him out
and if it is his last inning this has
been a
real good five innings for kyle muller
he fans nine in five innings
and we go to the sixth he leads three to
nothing
the center field eye drop backdrop
fly ball sent to right center field and
pretty deep heinemann going back he's at
the wall he leaps and
didn't get it home run austin riley
what a good at bat man he just kept
fouling off pitch after pitch and austin
riley with his 13th homer braves up four
to nothing
and to your point stayed to the big part
of the ballpark got a little bit of a
cutter that didn't do much
he smoked that ball right center field
[Applause]
braves need six outs shane green's
charge to get three of them
pitch
swing and a fly ball pretty well hit
center ender on the run still going
still going he's got it two steps shy of
the wall
the braves flashed some leather and
center in this series heredia the other
night ender in the eighth inning today
wow that's what a great luxury
heredia's played great center field and
when you make a change and you put ender
in the game you are losing nothing
defensively
[Applause]
the o2
he struck him out and the braves shut
out the reds four nothing your final
score
kyle muller earns his first major league
win a couple of long homers for acuna
and austin riley